von heute ab 9 uhr bis 23 uhr bis zum
ersten oktober muss man auf vielen
öffentlichen plätzen die masken tragen
und wie schon jetzt einmal ganz frisch
sein ob sich die münchner wirklich daran
halten unsere bild reporterin luisa
volkhausen ist für uns in münchen
unterwegs
lisa gibt uns doch mal ein kurzes
feedback wie diszipliniert sind die
münchner ja grundsätzlich muss man sagen
sind die münchner schon sehr
diszipliniert das hat man vor allem
darin gesehen dass du hast es gerade
gesagt die macht natürlich geht er seit
ein paar minuten aber die leute die auch
schon ab 8 uhr hier unterwegs waren
haben größtenteils maske getragen
aktuell werden die schilder die darauf
hinweisen dass man das getragen muss
auch erst aufgestellt 80 schilder sollen
an den zugängen zu den öffentlichen
plätzen jetzt darauf hinweisen dass die
massen pflicht gilt das heißt noch ist
es gar nicht so ganz klar die polizei
ist vorhin schon mal durch gefahren aber
größtenteils tragen die leute schon
maske wir sehen im hintergrund das ist
in münchen scheinbar geregnet hat wenn
er so ein bisschen regen natürlich auf
die masse kommt ist es wohl auch weniger
angenehm als er ohnehin schon mit maske
wie ist die laune der münchner sind sie
ein bisschen aufgeregt sind sie ein
bisschen genervt wie es so da ein
stimmungsbild also die leute mit denen
wir heute morgen schon sprechen könnten
haben die verschärfung der massen
positiv gesehen
wir haben wirklich gesagt na ja die
zahlen sind aktuell sehr hoch da muss
man reagieren wenn die maske hilft dann
tragen wir sie gerne dann nehmen wir das
auch in kauf klar sie ist unangenehm
aber da muss man einfach durch um das
irgendwie gesellschaft zu schützen
aktuell ist es hier auch noch nicht voll
also es hat geregnet das wetter ist
wirklich schlecht wenn man letzte woche
denkt wo es hier wirklich schon bei
schönem wetter sind diese plätze alle
sehr sehr gefüllt da wird man jetzt ein
bisschen schauen wie sich das die woche
über entwickelt und ja also da muss man
schauen arbeiten grundsätzlich nehmen
die münchner ist dann auch gut an
trotz regen trotz erschwerter
bedingungen tragen sie die maske tapfer
und was ist mit dem ordnungsamt haben
die heute schon ja viel und streng
kontrolliert was gibt es denn für
bußgelder
also das bußgeld nicht bei 250 euro ich
konnte gestern mit der polizei sprechen
die die kontrollen hier für die
kontrollen zuständig sein wird die haben
aber angekündigt dass man erstmal
natürlich auch auf die leute auch die
massen pflicht hinweist und dann immer
im einzelfall schaut ob das bußgeld
wirklich fällig ist oder ob man
tatsächlich die leute einfach mit kurzen
hinweis zu ermutigen kann die maske zu
tragen und wenn die leute dann auch
einsichtig sind soll es nicht sofort zum
bußgeld kommen
das geht ja wirklich auch gerade erst
mal darum dass die leute auch im wissen
dass die massen pflichtet bild wie
gesagt die schilder werden aktuell noch
aufgestellt
die polizei ist vorhin schon mal
durchgefahren aktuelles ist aber noch
ruhig es ist auch noch leer
also da ist die polizei heute mit dem
gewohnten aufgebot im einsatz und will
kontrollieren
mehr nachrichten um breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren